l'éléphant star de l'unité de
méthanisation du zoo de thoiry grâce à
la richesse de son fumier en effet le
zoo fourni 10 % des matières organiques
traités par touahri bioénergie les 90%
restants sont les déchets des
agriculteurs des habitants et des
communes des environs soirée d'énergie
c'est une unité de méthanisation
territoriale
ça veut dire que nous traitons ici les
déchets du territoire dans une proximité
d'environ 20 à 25 km autour de l' usine
est également nous restituons la matière
organique et l'énergie dans un rayon
très proche d'environ 10 km la
méthanisation
c'est le processus d'accélération de la
dégradation des déchets organiques
les déchets sont traités en cinq étapes
distinctes jusqu'à la récupération d'une
énergie appelé biogaz qui est envoyé
dans l'unité d'épuration ici on prépare
le biogaz forme de biométhane donc ça
veut dire qu'on sépare le dioxyde de
carbone du métal afin d'avoir donc un
gaz riche en méthane qui sont injectés
au réseau de gaz locale un processus
biologique doublement vertueux pour
récupérer un carbone vert mais également
une réutilisation des déchets une fois
traitées par les agriculteurs
ce procédé nous permet d'être de
dégrader le carbone sous forme d'énergie
en 21 jours donc c'est assez rapide
ensuite bien entendu pour la matière
organique qui doit retourner aux champs
là nous avons environ six mois de
stockage donc qui nous permet aussi de
parfaire cette matière qui retourne au
chant un processus locale qui aspirent à
s'étendre dans tout le territoire pour
réduire les trajets de transport des
matières organiques
quelqu'un pourrait ainsi agir contre le
réchauffement climatique en faisant
traiter ses déchets dans l' usine de
méthanisation la plus proche